my job is very very challenging every
day you're facing new issues you're
facing new topics the working
environment that we're in really is
unique because of its diversity and you
actually get to work with all those
people that come from different
countries and it's so interesting just
to be in this multicultural environment
you know you're doing an important job
and you're doing a job that tries to
make the world a better place actually
how many people can say that what they
do impacts the lives of more than 500
million people
you're really where the decisions are
being taken there is a long list of
things protecting the environment
helping create jobs supporting research
and innovation fighting poverty and
promoting equal opportunities I was both
amazed and surprised to see the vast
array of different jobs that are
actually on offer I work with lawyers
prosecutors translators policy officers
economists scientists there's such a
great offer in terms of training that
you're strongly encouraged to learn and
grow throughout your career I could
describe my colleagues as very
professional they are very committed
they are also having a lot of fun I
think that we do make a difference in
the lives of not only Europeans but
globally speaking it's the opportunity
of a lifetime
I shall I shall I did this one again